it is motorcycle awareness month and  with warmer weather out it's time to  remind everyone to be on alert and share  the road with motorcyclists a few ways  to be cautious drivers should be aware  of conditions around them maintain a  safe distance when following motorcycles  check their mirrors and blind spots  before changing lanes and of course pay  particular attention when making turns  across traffic even though driver  assistant technologies are being added  to newer cars and suvs drivers are urged  not to become careless  then we kind of ask that you  look twice look three times look for  everybody that's out there because like  i said it's not just about motorcycles  it's about pedestrians about bicyclists  according to our state fatal reports in  the past year up to march clark county  has seen 11 motorcyclists killed that's  about a round of a total rather of 59  deaths on our roads